Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Microsoft, please. Mal gucken, ob uns Microsoft wieder enttäuscht, weil wir
probieren heute WinUI 3.0 aus. Das kam vorgestern raus, erst im Review, da warte
ich ja schon seit der Ankündigung drauf, weil es die erste gescheite Sache seit
15 Jahren ist, die Microsoft für Desktop-Anwendungen rausgebracht hat oder
rausbringen wird oder denkt, rauszubringen, was auch immer. Aber ich muss erst mal
mal Streaming-Recher noch anmachen, also den zweiten, wo ich dann Vorschau habe
und alles. Deswegen seht ihr euch jetzt hier selbst im Chat. Ja, und zwar das hier,
guckt mal, WinUI 3.0, Review, Bre-View heißt ja Bre-View. Wir sind ja hier bekannt
dafür, dass wir besonders exzellent exquisit korrekt immer alles auf
Englisch aussprechen. So, Vorschau läuft. Vorschau läuft, wenn wir den ganzen Crap hier
ausmachen. Leute, ich muss mir gleich noch ein neues T-Shirt anziehen, ich komme
gerade von draußen, ich war hier, stellt euch mal vor, stellt euch das mal vor, ich
war im Wald. Guckt euch das mal an. Das ist mal richtig
MonkaS. Guckt euch das mal an.
Ja, in der Sonne. Ja, Monarch, richtig, Monarch S. Das ist das beste E-Mode dafür. Alle
einmal Monarch S. Das habe ich doch gar nicht drinne. Monarch S, das brauchen wir
noch. Monarch S und zwar Transparent. Das haben wir nicht. Ah, Monarch S Transparent,
exzellent. Gibt es das vielleicht auch in groß? Ah, meinetwegen, Safe Image. Monarch S, das
brauchen wir noch, ganz, ganz wichtig.
Monarch S, all das ist ein scheiß aufgelöstes GIF, äh, JIF, JPEG, JPG, was auch
immer. Google suche Dark Mode, keine Ahnung, das ist hier der Dark, der Dark Reader, aber
es gab irgendwie auch die Möglichkeit, glaube ich, mittlerweile, Chrome Native irgendwie
auf Dark Mode zu schalten. Zumindest, was wir uns heute angucken, ist das hier, guckt
mal hier, exzellent. Poggers, Five Head. Ähm, Leute, hat jemand von euch mal versucht,
ihr Bild, Bild 2020, Webcast, sich anzugucken. Ich bin dafür zu dumm, ich kriege das nicht
gebacken. Wenn man sich das hier anguckt und sagt, hier Sessions, Session Catalog, da gibt
es nämlich den Talk von einer halben Stunde zum neuen WinUI und, ähm, ah, das da? Oh,
wo ist der Talk? Der war doch schon. Wo ist er? Warum soll ich mich registrieren? Verstehe
ich nicht. Das, das kapier ich nicht. Nee, nee, nee, Adplog, glaube ich nicht. Nö.
Der Talk war schon, ich bin da einfach zu small brain für. Daddy Khan zwei Monate,
vier Monate? Nee, Moment. Monarch S. Vier Monate und zwei Monate in Folge. Ah, exzellent,
exzellent. Kein echter Gamer. Ja, ist so. Aber im Prinzip ziemlich, ähm, so Leute, ähm,
wir müssen jetzt jetzt, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, hier, hier stimmt, äh, hier stimmt der
Dark Mode aber mal gar nicht an. What the fuck? Das sieht überhaupt, okay. Was auch immer.
Oh, okay. Äh, also. Ah gut, warum nicht, machen wir da. Aber das Ding, das Ding kann
man in Dark Mode stellen. Die Microsoft-Seite kann man, ich weiß, dass das geht. Ich hab
die nämlich bei mir auf dem Desktop auch im Dark Mode. Man kann die Microsoft-Hilfe-Seite
irgendwie in Dark Mode stellen. Wo war das nochmal? Irgendwo ging, das ging, das ging,
ich weiß, dass das ging. Ja, hier, theme. Dark, exzellent. So, und das probier mal aus,
Leute. Ähm, ich muss ja aber kurz mal schnell ein neues T-Shirt anziehen, weil ich bin
noch etwas, äh, Monarch-S. Gleich wieder am Start.
So, wieder am Start. So Leute, und wenn wir hier fertig sind, so in zwei Stunden oder
so, mal gucken, so 13 Uhr rum, oder vielleicht 13.3, mal gucken, wann es losgeht, ähm,
dann, ähm, und uns mit danach ist, dann machen wir Warzone-Stream Only-Only-Wins. Heute wird
nur gewonnen. Hast du schon die neuen Features von C-Shop 9 angesehen? Wir haben uns ein
paar Previews angeguckt, ja. Ähm, mir ist aber jetzt nix so richtig, eine Sache fand
ich richtig cool, aber ich komm grad nicht mehr drauf, was das war. Eins fand ich mega
praktisch. Was war das denn noch mal? Ähm, was war das denn hier noch mal? Das da war
es nicht. Das war es, glaub ich, auch nicht. Equality. Das war ganz nice, aber es gab
doch noch was anderes. Das war auch ganz cool. Parameter-Null-Checking. Ja, das war cool,
aber das war klar, dass so was in der Richtung kommt. Lambda-Discords fand ich sehr praktisch,
dass es jetzt endlich offiziell drin ist. Ähm, was war das denn? Irgendwas anderes
fand ich ultra praktisch, aber ich hab vergessen was. Ja. Init-Only-Properties, ok, das ist
ganz nett. Aber ist das schon Final? Oder sind das noch, ähm, wie heißt es, so RFC-mäßig?
Oder ist das schon Final? Ahm, ähm, Records? Propositional? Hm. Wow! Wow, ok, ok, ok, ok,
wow, ok. Das ist eigentlich ganz cool. Das ist dann eher so Richtung Go sieht das aus
fast schon. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Go braucht ja auch eine Main-Function. Hier,
das ist cool, das ist cool. Improved-Pattern-Matching ist cool. Ähm, das ist sehr, das ist sehr
nice, dass man jetzt quasi das abkürzen kann und sich das New-Point sparen kann. Ähm,
hier müssen wir uns echt mal im Detail angucken. Alter, Wald. So, ähm, also was brauchen wir
denn dafür, dass wir den Kram ausprobieren können? Das ist mal zur Erklärung was das
Ganze ist. Ähm, ich verstehe gar nicht warum das nicht mehr Hype auslöst. Das Ding ist
seit 15 Jahren das erste UI, neue UI für Windows, was man verwenden kann richtig. Das
letzte UI was man sinnvoll verwenden kann war WPF. Danach kam WinRT, UWP, haste nicht
gesehen, geschiss. Das konnte man nicht richtig verwenden. Das Problem, um das nochmal kurz
zu recapen, ähm, was das Problem an UWP ist, äh, der neue Package Manager für Windows,
den schreibe ich mir mal auf, den wollte ich mir auch nochmal angucken, genau. Stream-Idee
hatten wir doch hier irgendwo so eine, so, also, ähm, äh, Windows Package Manager, äh,
9.0, C Sharp 9.0. Genau, um nochmal kurz zu erklären was das Problem an der ganzen Geschichte
war, warum Windows UI so gesagt hat und warum, warum die meisten Windows-Software heute keine
richtige Windows-Software ist, sondern eher so eine Mischung aus entweder Electron, also
in Browser oder Qt oder sonst was. Das liegt daran, das letzte, ich glaube 2006 hat Microsoft
UWP rausgebracht und danach kam nix mehr. Nach UWP kam WinRT und UWP und Crap. Und das
Problem an UWP war, ähm, dass du heute eigentlich immer noch nicht UWP richtig verwenden kannst.
Also meistens, UWP und WinRT ist so ein zusammenhängendes Ding, also sprich, jedes Programm
was du machst hat, hat ne Sandbox drum herum. Was schonmal scheiße ist, ja. Es gibt Möglichkeiten,
dass man das quasi sich rappt, da braucht man quasi, muss man den Prozess starten, der
dann auf alles zugreifen kann und so, mega wirkt. Und das hauptsächlich Problem an UWP-Anwendung
ist die, die Verteilung von den Anwendungen. Also sprich, man hat die eine Möglichkeit,
das hier über den Microsoft Store zu machen, aber das ist ja nur wirklich, was anderes
fällt mir zum Microsoft Store nicht mehr ein. Also niemand möchte wirklich auf den Microsoft
Store angewiesen sein. Und das ist die eine Möglichkeit, UWP-Anwendungen zu verteilen.
Die andere Möglichkeit ist, UWP-Anwendungen über den eigenen Installer zu verteilen.
Das ist ja kein Ding, da sind ja die Windows Leute dran gewöhnt. Windows Leute mögen
ja Installer, Setup, Exe und sonst was. So, das Problem ist jetzt, du brauchst ein Codesigning-Zertifikat
um UWP-Anwendungen beziehungsweise um die selbst verteilen zu können. Und niemand, der einfach
mal so Anwendungen entwickelt und nicht gerade in irgendeiner größeren Firma arbeitet,
die die Anwendung entwickelt, kauft sich ein Codesigning-Zertifikat. Das kostet 300 Euro
im Jahr über den Daumen gepeilt und nur das dafür, dass ich dann Windows-Anwendungen machen
kann. Es hat noch ein paar andere Probleme, aber voll für den Arsch. So, und was Microsoft
mit WinUI 3 macht, ist endlich seit 15 Jahren. Ohne Scheiße. Die letzten 15 Jahre war Microsoft
so. Mit WinUI 3 ist Microsoft hoffentlich wieder so. Die haben ihre GUI-Geschichte von
UWP genommen. Also das da ist zum Beispiel eine UWP-Anwendung. Ist jetzt ein scheiß
Beispiel, weil der Taschenrechner ist abartig hässlich. Wir können uns auch mal den Kalender
angucken. Das ist auch eine UWP-Anwendung, die sieht ein bisschen schöner aus. Also
die haben ihre GUI-Geschichte genommen und haben gesagt, okay, wir erlauben jetzt auch
ganz normale Windows-Anwendungen mit dieser Oberfläche. So, und das ist im Endeffekt,
was hinter WinUI 3.0 steckt. So, jetzt müssen wir nur noch gucken, wie man den Kram installiert
kriegt. Getting started. Wahrscheinlich müssen wir jetzt erst das halbe Internet installieren,
weil es Microsoft ist. Also was brauchen wir? To use WinUI 4 Desktop Project. Make sure
that you have Windows Version 13 Pro... Haben wir bestimmt, oder? Wo sieht man das überhaupt,
was für eine Windows-Version man hat? WinFair, CMD. War das da WinFair? Excellent, haben
wir. Das haben wir schon mal. Oh, okay. Soll ich noch ein Wishl Studio... Sind die das
Wahnsinns? Ich hab Wishl Studio 17 drauf. 17 können wir mal remove. 17 können wir mal
remove. 17, remove, remove. Piss dich alle. 17 können wir mal. Wobei... Ah, ich hab genug
Platz für einen Dritter, easy. Okay, ähm... Nee, Moment, was? Install Wishl Studio 16.7
Brifue 1. See? Wishl Studio Brifue muss ich installieren, okay? Community. Alles klar.
Das geht relativ schnell, nachdem sich Vodafone jetzt ja eingekriegt hat. Piss dich alle!
Äh, wie ist Community? 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Excellent Passwort. Wishl Studio Installer...
Ja. Nicht Community. So, also das, was wir installieren. Ähm, dann brauchen wir... Was?
Man muss.NET 5, Brifue 4, 32-Bit und 64-Bit installieren, okay? Ah, yes, excellent. Machen
wir, machen wir alles. Ähm,.NET Desktop Development, UWP Development, wir installieren mal den...
Oh, 14 Gigabyte, was ist da los? So ein Verarsch, ey. Was für ein Workload müssen wir installieren?
Okay,.NET Desktop Development müssen wir auf jeden Fall installieren. Ich glaub, UWP
können wir, können wir uns... Blend brauchen wir nicht. Entity Framework Tools brauchen
wir auch nicht. Profiler, Just-In-Time-Debugger. Was brauchen da auf einmal so viel Speicherplatz?
Eben war es, eben, eben war es doch noch angeblich 14, 14G. Hä? Habt, wo, wo ist das jetzt so
vor einmal hin? Hä? Hä? What the fuck? Ist die Größenberechnung im Arsch oder so? Kann
das sein? Ah, Blend brauchen wir nicht. Install while downloading. Ah, install, gut, geht
ja schnell. Max, bist du bereits geleakt? Ich bin schon 20.000 Mal geleakt. Ich bin
in der Suppe geleakt, ich bin im Fernseher geleakt, ich bin in der Verpackung geleakt,
ich bin überall geleakt. Okay. PopOS hat mir nicht gefallen. Haben wir im Stream ausprobiert.
So, also den müssen wir installieren. BrickView 1. Ich hau mir jetzt einfach mal die ganzen
Crap drauf. Oh Leute, kann das sein, dass die, dass ihr nix seht? Kann das sein, dass
ihr nix seht? Nee, oder? Ihr seht was? Ja, meine Vorschau, meine Vorschau spackt gerade
richtig rum. Die ist, meine Vorschau ist hier. Monarch S. Ich glaube ich weiß woran das liegt.
Windows hat bestimmt mal wieder die Soundsettings umgestellt. Das macht Windows nämlich gerne.
Ja, okay, geht. Nein, geht nicht. Okay, also anscheinend sind die Soundsettings doch richtig.
Woher kommt das? Ja, das ist neu. Okay. Während der Kram installiert. Close. Jetzt müssen
wir das noch installieren. Wir haben wahrscheinlich jetzt erstmal 40 MB Microsoft Crap drauf
installiert. Install. Und nebenbei nicht vergessen mal die OBS-Stats aufzumachen, dass nix
abkackt. Seit ich VoiceMeter verwende, forscht mir Windows nicht mehr rein, okay. Jetzt hatte
ich auch mal eine ganze Weile drauf, vielleicht soll ich das wieder installieren. VoiceMetors.
Okay, das ist auch klar installiert. Das haben wir auch erzählt. Also, Visual Studio haben
wir drauf..NET Core 5. Briefview haben wir. Oh, das heißt ja nicht mal Core. Sorry Leute.
.NET 5. Die wollen ja die Leute verwirren. Also, nur mal zur Erklärung..NET 5 ist eigentlich
.NET Core 5, beziehungsweise eigentlich.NET Core 4. Sie haben es jetzt allerdings das Core
gestrichen.NET 5 genannt. Und nicht zu verwechseln mit dem.NET Framework 4.8. Man könnte ja
denken, dass.NET 5 der Nachfolger des.NET Framework 4.8 ist. Aber das stimmt nicht..NET
5 ist eigentlich.NET Core 4 und hat mit.NET Framework 4.8 nichts zu tun. Exzellent Microsoft
Logik. Beste. Microsoft Benahmung, die haben es drauf. Was will er machen? Ich will WinUI
3 ausprobieren. Okay, ich glaube, wir haben noch nicht alles installiert. So, bla, bla,
bla, bla, bla, bla, bla. Download WinUI Briefview 1 Physics. Ah, das ist eine Visual Studio
Extension. Ah, schon eine ganze Bewertung. Wir sehen ja Absolut Bleeding Edge heute dabei.
Und was kann WinUI? WinUI ist quasi die GUI-Technologie, die unter den ganzen neuen Windows-Anwendungen
drunter steckt, mit dem großen Unterschied, dass man keine UVP-Anwendung mehr machen muss,
sondern so eine ganz normale Win32-Anwendung machen kann und dementsprechend darauf das
komplette System zugreifen kann. Also ich habe mir überlegt, was wir heute ausprobieren
ist. Wir gucken, ob wir Files auflisten können. Das ist da quasi Absolut Noob-Style. Dann
gucken wir, ob wir einen GIF abgespielt bekommen, weil ich habe die Hoffnung, dass ich damit
eine besseres GIF-Wiedergabe hinbekomme als mit meiner UVP-Anwendung. Und als letztes
probieren wir dann auch Screenshots anzeigen. Also quasi Desktop-Capture. Desktop-Capture
mit und dann in den Fenster rein. Mal gucken. So. Physics Installer. Exzellent. Und für
welches Visual Studio installiert er das jetzt? Das wird in C-Sharp gebastelt. Visual Studio
Preview. Exzellent. Perfekt. Ja in F-Sharp kannst du das auch machen, aber da sitzen
wir morgen noch. Hast du morgen frei? Ja. Was installiert der dann da für 30 Milliarden
Sachen? Aber. 20 MB Download und erstmal eine halbe Stunde installieren. Ach nee, der installiert
die UVP-Geschichte. Was auch immer. Microsoft, mach einfach. Mach einfach. Vollkommen. Wie
viel Festplattenplatz habe ich denn eigentlich noch? Ah, 53G. Das soll... Moment. Ich hatte
80 davor. Hat das wirklich 30 GB gefressen gerade? Sehe ich das richtig? What the fuck?
Was haben die mir denn da draufgehauen? Ist da schon die nächste Win-House-Version mit
vorinstalliert? Genau, wie in Modern Warfare Update. Keg Triple U. Also wenn das Keg W
ist, dann ist dann Keg Triple U ist dann... Oh, das war Payne's Champ-Witz, Alter. Monarch
S. So, also jetzt haben wir das installiert. Ich glaube, das war es danach. Wenn der Kram
durch ist, so in 20 Stunden, dann... Was installiert der da eigentlich alles? Leute, guckt euch
mal den Verbraucher an. Es geht immer weiter runter. Gleich ist die Festplatte voll. Keg
W. Das brauchen wir auch noch als Emote. Gibt's das transparent? Gibt's das transparent?
Keg W. Nein, ich brauche Keg W als... Warum tauche ich unter Keg W auf? Okay. Okay,
okay. Aha. Was ist denn das beste Keg W emote? Der da? Ne. Das ist übelste low quality emote.
Das müssen wir anderweitig. Ich brauche ein ordentliches, hochaufgelöstes Keg W. Wie
sieht es denn aus mit Pause-Champ? Gibt's das ordentlich hochaufgelöst? Ah, exellent,
das brauchen wir. Pause-Champ. In der Zeit, wo Visual Studio hier am installen... Ach,
du Scheiße, was macht... 50,7... Was installiert mir das alles? Monkeys. Ich glaube, ich muss
erst mal Festplattenplatz freigeben, klar. Pause. Was? Pause-Champ. Was? Oh, oh, es
hat sich selbst aufgeräumt wieder. Ich habe gedacht, 80 Gigabyte reichen für eine Briefview,
Leute. Ich weiß, das ist ziemlich blöd gewesen, aber ich habe gedacht, 80G sind genug. Haben
sich eigentlich Leute bei dem Geschlechts-Tweet über Telekom beschwerten? Ne, ne. Wir beobachten
dich Windows-Installer. Der Windows-Installer wird genau beobachtet. Was macht das Ding
denn da? Das installiert mir glaube ich wirklich irgendwie... Vielleicht hätte ich das besser
in einer VM machen sollen. Das installiert mir da wirklich 30 Millionen Sachen drauf.
Ich hoffe, man kann das ordentlich deinstallieren wieder. 50. Wir haben jetzt ziemlich genau
30 Gigabyte verbraucht schon. Stimmt, wir haben keinen Pause-Champ drin. Warum haben
wir das nicht? Das haben wir gleich, Leute. Franger-Faces-Z. E-Modes. Haben wir gleich,
haben wir gleich, Leute. Gleich ist Pause-Champ drinnen. Pause-Champ. Oh, edit. Oh, ist
das drinne, Leute. Kann sein, dass ihr Refreshen müsst. Es kann auch sein, dass es eine Weile
dauert bis es gesyncht ist, aber ich habe es in FFZ eingefügt. Also Leute, die FFZ
haben und den Chat Refreshen sollten es jetzt eigentlich gleich sehen. Pause-Champ. Ich
hätte jetzt nicht gedacht, dass der da... Wir gucken mal mit dem Prozess-Explorer, was
das Ding da macht. Nehradorn-Stufe 1 für 10 Monate. Exzellent. Exzellent-Subscription.
Na ja, so wirklich viel machen tut er nicht, ne? Na gut, während er installiert, habe ich
mal eine andere Frage an euch, Chat. Das ist bestimmt so der typische Microsoft-Installer.
Der macht jetzt so und gleich... Ich habe eine andere Frage an euch. Und zwar, mein
Mousepad ist übelst im Arsch. Also aktuell habe ich ja das da als Mousepad. Das Ding.
Ne, das... Was haben die denn alles für Mousepads? Hiro Plus, Taito, Kanga. Kanga ist... Hier,
das da habe ich aktuell. Und eine G403. So, ich bin jetzt gerade am Überlegen. Ah, Chat-Big-Brain-Empfehlung
sehe ich hier gerade. Was ist mit der Handballen-Auflage? Dies ist auch nicht schlecht, oder? Naja, zumindest...
Was will das denn? Zumindest habe ich mir jetzt überlegt, ob ich von diesem Rocket Hero und
der G403, ob ich nicht umsteigen soll auf eine G Pro Wireless. Also quasi... Leute, was ist
da der Unterschied? Was ist da der Unterschied? Außer 10 Euro. Deutsches Mouse-Layout. Ich
habe echt keine Ahnung, was der Unterschied zwischen den zwei Dingern ist. Ah, die eine
ist nicht auf Lager. Und die andere schon. Ah, verstehe. Big-Brain. Okay, also ich überlege,
ob ich mir das hier holen soll. Und ein... Wie heißt das andere? G903. Ne, ne. Äh, äh.
Wie heißt das? Wie heißt das Auflademaus-Pad nochmal? EU-Version bei einer Maus? Die deutsche
Version ist breiter. Ne. Hä? Das ist eine Maus. Deutsches Maus-Layout. Ähm... Die Verpackung.
Achso. Ah, gut. Okay, als... Okay, wie hieß dieses Wireless-Charging-Ding nochmal? Charging-Maus-Pad.
Das da, genau. So, und ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich mir jetzt nicht die Kombi hier kaufe.
G-Bro? Bro? Und, äh, ein G-Powerplay. Wie groß ist das? Das ist nice, so. Okay, hast
du das, Tribolon? Ähm... Wie groß ist denn das? 27x32. Das müsste ziemlich so groß sein
wie das, was ich aktuell auch habe. Aktuell habe ich das hier. Das ist noch ein bisschen
älter. Ähm, wie groß ist das? 35x25, ja. Ey, das ist ziemlich genauso groß wie mein
aktuelles Maus-Pad, ne? 27x32. 35x5. Ich glaube, das sind einfach nur die Abmaße irgendwie
anders. Wobei, das ist eher hoch als breit, kann das sein? Ist das eher hoch als breit?
Auf der anderen Seite, man kann es ja drehen, wie man will. Man kann es ja drehen, wie man
will. Es spricht doch eigentlich überhaupt nichts dagegen, wenn ich das hoch kann drehe.
Also sprich, wenn ich das hier am rechten Schreibtischrand nehme. Ich kann es ja drehen,
wie ich lustig bin. Ich muss das ja nicht hochkant legen, ne? Also so wird es ja gegen
die Richtung Monitor zeigen. Oh, wir sind fertig. Exzellent, wir haben es geschafft.
Das G ist gedreht. Ja, das juckt mich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht. Jurok ruft die Polizei.
Da guckt einer, äh, Dings hier. Wie heißt er? Slap Like, wie heißt er? Davy, Davy 405?
Der Bass, der Bass-Typ. Slap Like, der sagt auch immer I'm calling the police. Davy 504,
genau, ja, so. Ok, wir sind fertig. Also wahrscheinlich hole ich mir die Kombi. Ich meine, ein bisschen
größeres Mousepad wäre schon nicht schlecht. Da könnte ich meine Sensitivity vielleicht
noch einen Ticken runterstellen. Aber die Kombi aus, ähm, Wireless und Wireless Charging
ist irgendwie schon cool. Was nicht so cool ist, muss man auch ehrlich gesagt mal sagen,
ich meine 240 Euro für ein Maus und ein Mauspad ist schon mal echt eine Hausnummer, ne? Muss
man die oft aufladen? Ne, das Mauspad lädt ja auf. Deswegen ist es eigentlich wahrscheinlich
ganz praktisch. Oder aber vielleicht lohnt es sich auch mit einem normalen Mauspad und
wenn man die nur einmal alle drei Monate aufladen muss oder so, dann hm. Na gut, also wir haben
alles installiert, dann gucken wir uns das ganze doch jetzt mal an. Ja Kio-kun, keine
Ahnung ob sich das lohnt, das müssen wir erstmal gucken. Wofür gibst du denn sonst
kein Geld aus? Ja gar nicht eigentlich. Die Logitech Mäuse sind viel zu schwer. Das andere
was ich mir überlegt hab, ist das hier. Ähm, aber die musste die importieren, das ist auch
für den Arsch. Äh, äh, wo gibts denn die Mäuse? Ach keine Ahnung. Die ist doch, die
G Pro ist doch relativ leicht, oder? Guck mal. Was wiegt denn die? 80 Gramm, so. Ne G403,
was wiegt ne G403? Moment, ne 80 Gramm ist mit Verpackung, ne? 80 Gramm ist mit Verpackung.
Da müssen wir mal bei Logitech gucken. Äh, wait, wait. Äh, also 87 Gramm und die, alter
Logitech, wo kann man suchen bei euch? G Pro Wireless? Die da wahrscheinlich, ne? Wiegt
was? Nein, ich will nicht Subscribern. Höchstens, höchstens auf Twitch, aber nicht bei Logitech.
Wiegt 80. Ähm, ist sogar noch ein bisschen leichter als meine G403. Wie viel wiegt denn
ne Finalmouse? Was, warte mal. Pro Settings. Was hat ein Scream? Was hat ein Scream von
ne Maus? Der hat glaub ich ne Finalmouse. Das sind die, das hier. Finalmouse Ultralight
Sunset. Mal gucken, was das Ding wiegt. Ähm, steht das da irgendwo vielleicht? So ein bisschen
Hardware-Informationen zu? Gibt's nicht. Das ist overrated. Hardware-Informationen braucht
man nicht. Äh, nein. Die wiegt bestimmt nicht 227 Gramm. Der, der bearded Bob. Aha. What?
67 Gramm. Da hätten sie es auch 69 Gramm machen können, oder? Ich mein, wenn schon,
wenn man mal die, die Möglichkeit hat, der hätte man das auch gleich richtig machen
können. Okay. Also, auf geht's. Ähm, jetzt müssen wir uns den Guide kurz angucken.
Also. Getting started. Create WinUI 3 in Desktop App. Ähm, okay, es gibt anscheinend
neue Vorlagen. Create New Project. WinUI. Win, Windows Runtime Component. UWP. Nein.
Wir wollen eine Desktop Anwendung. WinUI in Desktop. Packaged. Nein, nein, nein, ich will
nix. Ich will nix. Packaged. Plank App. Packaged. Okay. Language. C-Sharp. Ich will kein UWP.
Class Library. Packaged. Hä? Nein, ich will das nicht über den Microsoft Store machen.
Ich will ne stinknormale, publische Win32 WinUI Anwendung. Ich will nix sideloaden. Ich will
nix über den Store. Wollt ihr mich veräppeln? Gibt's das nicht? Dann wird der Scheiß sofort
installiert. Ich will das nicht über den Store machen. Das ist doch grad der Witz
daran. Okay. Probiert, probiert. Plank App. Nee, das ist, Plank App ist UWP. Wir wollen
keine UWP. Wir wollen, wir wollen ne Win32 Desktop. Okay, es gibt, das ist das Einzige.
Na schauen wir mal. Okay, Create. Nein. Ich will kein UWP Shit. Geh weg. Was soll ich
mit diesem verschissenen UWP kack? Das ist doch grad der Witz an dem, dass man den UWP
Scheiß nicht mehr braucht. Ja, MSIX ist aber kacke. Da braucht man wieder irgendwelche
Codesigning Certificates, dass man das ausführen kann. Okay, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Vielleicht ist das ja auch alles nur. What? Alter, Microsoft, wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Ich will kein Store und ich will kein Site. Ich will ne beschissene, stinknormale Windows-Anwendung,
die ich anklicken kann und starten. Ist das euer Ernst? Ihr wollt mir noch nicht wirklich
erzählen, ihr habt den ganzen Aufwand gemacht, dafür, dass ich immer noch den gleichen Scheiß-Limitierung,
okay, nicht alle, aber was, die ganze Zertifikatsgeschichte hab, die bei UWP sackt. Das wollt ihr mir
noch nicht wirklich erzählen, Microsoft, oder? Okay, wir starten das Ding mal. He didn't
know. Ja, als wüsstest du's. Ja, starten, please. Was? Was? Ist das euer Ernst? Ich
soll wirklich den UWP-Scheiß noch machen, oder was? Nee, nee, also man muss den Developer-Mode
anmachen, dafür, dass man sideloaden kann. Ich will nicht sideloaden, ich will eine ganz
normale, stinknormale Win32-Anwendung machen. Okay, vielleicht kriegen wir den Kram selbst
irgendwie gestartet. Wo ist, wo ist mein Main? Wo ist mein Main? Hier. So, wir gibaten das
jetzt. Wir gibaten das jetzt. Also, WSB, wir gibaten das jetzt. Create New Project, Console,
so kann man die.NET Core-Version auswählen. Okay, create. Wir bauen das jetzt nach, ohne
den ganzen UWP-Crap, das geht aber wahrscheinlich nicht. Okay, Moment, erst mal Dark Mode, Dark
Mode. Wie geht? Äh, Moment, ich hab schon lang kein Whistlestudio mehr auf gehabt, wo
ging das jetzt hier? Dark, Theme. Wo ist das nochmal versteckt in Whistlestudio? Was, Direkt
am Anfang? General? Ah, Dark. Ah, yes, okay, viel besser. Okay, viel besser. Gucken wir
mal, ob wir jetzt die Konsolen-Anwendung starten können. Excellent. Es ist ein.NET 5, okay,
dann, wir bauen das jetzt einfach nach, so. So, jetzt muss man natürlich irgendwas verlinken,
dass das funktioniert. Was muss man hier referenzieren? Dependencies, Packages, Microsoft WinUI. Geht
das Panuget, oder wie kann man das jetzt hier ver... WinUI? Wie kann man den Kram jetzt
hier auswählen? Ja, excellent. Ja, den will ich haben. Microsoft WinUI heißt der Kram.
Alter, Windows, Windows, please. Ich, ich werd garantiert keine UVP-Anwendung machen,
die... Also, ich werd keine Win32-Anwendung machen, die, die UVP zeugt... Ah, Microsoft,
das tut doch weh. Okay, ähm, wie kriegen wir denn Kram jetzt hin? Add? Add reference?
Nee. Fuck, wie kriegt man hier überhaupt wieder normale... Reference? Ah, okay. Browse?
Browse? Add? Nee, äh, build? Nate? Waaah! Include? Limp? Aha! Excellent! Da ist es.
Okay, jetzt haben wir das ge-edit. Oh, geht mir das schon wieder auf den Sack. Ich hab
schon wieder keinen Bock mehr auf den, auf den Microsoft Crap, Alter. Ah, jetzt müssen
wir Windows, Windows müssen wir include. Windows SDK müssen wir include. Wo, wo, wo
gibt's das her? Microsoft Windows SDK net. Wo kriegt man das her? Warum genau sollte
man das statt Qt verwenden? Ja gar nicht, wenn das so scheiße ist, wie es hier aussieht.
Okay, welche Version ist das? 6, 2, 3, preview? Okay, install, excellent. Kannst du nicht
einfach das Startprojekt ändern? Ja, das ist eine gute Idee, das probieren wir mal aus,
Kleil. Hat das jetzt installiert? Ah, excellent. Ha! Es startet schon mal, okay. So, und jetzt
muss ich gucken, wie ich die Anwendung starte. Äh, wo, wo ist denn mein Main? Wo ist denn
hier mein Main? Wo ist denn, wo ist denn hier Main, Main Window? App? Wo ist denn hier
mein Main? Wo ist denn hier der Einstieg überhaupt? Wie geht denn das? Wie startet der, den Kram
überhaupt? Es muss doch irgendwo eine Main geben, was den Kram lädt, oder nicht? Hm.
Das wird ja auf den UWP Package Plot Check gesetzt. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie der Kram
funktioniert. Ich weiß nur, dass ich ein Codesigning Zertifikat dafür brauche für 300 Euro im
Jahr, und Microsoft kann mich mal am Arsch lecken. Ähm, wie wird denn der Kram gestartet hier
überhaupt jetzt? App, App Application? Das Main, wo ist der Kram? Äh, als Startprojekt,
wurscht. Achso, hier oben meinste. Ähm, App 1. Das startet nix. Äh, RealRenax, doch,
kannst du? Kannst du? Du musst, du musst irgendwie unten links bei der Windows 10 Installation
musst du irgendwie auf, auf, man muss irgendwas, irgendwas anklicken. Ähm, und, und ich, wir
haben es in der VM gemacht, kriegst du mal. Okay. Aber irgendwo muss doch ein Main, irgendwo
muss doch mal ein Main sein. Irgendwo muss doch Main. Warum ist denn der Scheiß so kompliziert?
Current Project, Main. Ah, this is the first line of other. Ah, Logical Equivalent to
Main. Okay. Okay, denn Main, Main gibt's nicht. Okay, okay, okay. Window. Okay, okay. Kann
man sagen, New, Window. Geht so was? Window. Und dann muss ich aber irgendwie erstmal
Application, Application Run machen. Application. Ich, ich probier einfach mal rum. Ich hab Application
Run. Nee, Start. Start so. Boah, fuck man, ich hab keinen Schimmer, wie das funktioniert.
Wie startet man den Kram? Wie? Ich hab legit keine Ahnung, wie man den Kram startet. Ich
vermute ja fast, das geht nur mit diesem ganzen UWP-Shit. Das ärgert mich. App. Ah,
okay, man muss, man muss anscheinend. Ah, kann das sein, dass man sich ne eigene Klasse
von dem App machen muss? Und dann was passiert? Setz mal nen Breakpoint. Das juckt den überhaupt
nicht. Äh, wenn man das, wenn man das als Startprojekt hat, mag er nicht. Der macht,
der macht gar nix, Alter. Der, der macht gar nix. Der sollte eigentlich das hier starten,
macht er aber nicht. Okay, also, sagen wir mal hier. Application. Application. Und dann
ne? Callback. Was muss der da callbacken? Was muss der da callbacken? Wie sowas? Okay,
ich hab keine Ahnung, was da jetzt passiert. Kann Universal Studios mal formatieren, richtig?
Class not registered. Okay, das ist okay, das leuchtet ein. Das muss man wahrscheinlich
im Application starten machen. Ah, what? Das geht ohne den UWP-Shit nicht. Das geht mit,
ich sag mal, wo ist denn da der Sinn von? Das versteh ich null, äh. Guckt mal, das
ganze Zeug, angeblich, angeblich geht das ohne diesen ganzen UWP und Microsoft Store
Shit. Aber dass es funktioniert, brauch ich UWP und Microsoft Store Shit. Wo ist denn
da der Sinn dahinter? Okay, warte mal, wir machen nochmal ein neues Projekt. Renewal.
Plank App, UWP. Nein, wollen wir schonmal nicht. Ich will kein UWP. Okay, C++, was gibt's
da? Plank App Desktop. Das ist genau der gleiche Mist. Was war? DLL, aber das brauch ich ja
nicht. Okay, wind github, github, wind ui. Das, das macht mich schon wieder fertig, ja.
Ja, ja. Ja, genau das.
was? Ich will keine Packaged App. Für eine Packaged App brauch ich dieses, dieses
hässliche, brauch ich ein hässliches Codesigning Zertifikat. Was macht Microsoft denn da wieder
für Dinger? Wo ist denn das Problem, Microsoft? Ihr bringt ein neues UI Framework raus, wo
ich einfach eine App, wo ich einfach, ich sag schon eine App, wo ich einfach eine Anwendung
erstellen kann, ohne irgendwas anderes. Issue 2179. Hatt ich das gerade? Nee. Ja, use
mir nur wieder aus UWP. Not using, genau. Ja, genau, genau. Ja, schön, aber wir haben
jetzt ja das Preview. Das ist, es ist Schwachsinn, es stimmt überhaupt nicht, was ihr da schreibt,
Microsoft. Ich will kein UWP. Krieg, krieg Anfälle. Ich krieg echt Anfälle. Das ist
das ganze UWP Shit. Wobei, ich sag mal, an sich, an sich ist es okay, dass es diese UWP
im Windows Store Geschichten gibt. Für Sachen, für Leute, die die verwenden wollen, ist
das okay. Aber ich will eine stinknormale Windows Anwendung, ohne 30 Milliarden Sachen
vor allem, ohne 300 Euro Codesigning Zertifikat im Jahr. Also das Problem ist ja, nur mal
um euch das nochmal zu verdeutlichen, so. Man braucht, dass man diese Anwendung starten
kann. Also ich zeige es euch mal, wenn man die starten will. Sagt ihr mir ja immer, aktiviere
den Developer Mode. Das ist glaube ich, ja, das war eben Pokémon Musik. Oder ist das
jetzt immer noch? Kann sein. Das davor war glaube ich. So, der sagt hier, ich soll meine
Developer, den Developer Account aktivieren, damit ich Apps sideloaden kann. So. Das geht
bei mir lokal auf der Kiste, weil da stellt sich ein selbstsigniertes Zertifikat aus.
Das Problem ist jetzt, wenn ich das programmiere und ihr ladet euch das runter und wollt es
bei euch starten, dann geht es nicht. Es geht nur, wenn ihr vorher mein Zertifikat bei euch
in den Trust Store importiert, dass euer Windows dann der Anwendung vertraut. Das macht kein
normaler Anwender. Der denkt, Alter, was will der Typ von mir? Zumal du Adminrechte dafür
brauchst. Du brauchst ja sogar Adminrechte dafür. Also du hast aktuell die Auswahl, du
holst dir den Code Signing Zertifikat für 300 Euro im Jahr, dass du Windows Anwendung
machen darfst in Zukunft. Moderne. Oder aber, du machst es über den Microsoft Store. Was
ein Bullshit Microsoft. Alter. Oh Gott. Die kriegen, jetzt machen sie einmal was Gescheites
seit 15 Jahren und dann funktioniert es nicht. Kuluki97, neun Monate, dankeschön. Exzellenz
Subscription. Ich glaube, ich habe jede Menge Subscribers überszenen, oder? Ich muss mal
nachgucken. Ich gehe jetzt Warzone spielen, Kleine. Nee, jetzt noch nicht. Erst in einer
Stunde oder eineinhalb Stunden. Lerado hat auch Subscribed, dankeschön. Der Dekan auch.
Exzellenz Subscriptions. Macht die Microsofts Sache nicht besser. Okay, also die Briefview
ist explizit für Win32 Anwendungen. Das schreiben sie hier, guckt. Ich will keine Packaged App.
Geht mir nicht auf den Sack. Ich will es nicht Packaged haben. Genau das hier, genau
das. Das, was er schreibt. Der einzige Unterschied, den ich aktuell sehe, zwischen der UWP WinUI
3 Anwendung und einer Win32 WinUI Anwendung ist, dass man keine Sandbox hat. Aber die
ganzen anderen Scheiß, also der hauptsächliche Scheiß, nämlich ein Codesigning Zertifikat
oder den Microsoft Store, braucht man immer noch. Komplett useless wasted, Alter. Der
ganze Aufwand ist voll von Arsch. Kosta2570, Stufe 1, dankeschön. Exzellenz Subscription.
So, wie lösche ich den Kram jetzt wieder? Weg. Wie lösche ich den überhaupt wieder?
Fickt euch, ey. Ich habe mich da so drauf gefreut, dass man endlich im Jahr 2020 mal
wieder ordentliche Windows Desktop Anwendungen machen kann. Ne, geht nicht. Man könnte ja,
man könnte ja auf die Idee kommen, die wollen gerade, dass alles nur noch in Elektron gebastelt
wird. Da gibt es auch einen Tipp von Microsoft. Ja, welchen denn? Der Tipp von Microsoft ist,
man kann in den Browser, oder was? Codesigning ist doch dafür gut. Ja, natürlich, natürlich
ist Codesigning seine Anwendungszwecke, aber so als 0815 normaler Entwickler, der daheim
sitzt und irgendwas bastelt, ich kauf mir kein 300 Euro Codesigning Zertifikat. Seh ich
überhaupt nicht ein. Und man braucht den Scheiß ja überhaupt nicht. Es ist komplett unsinnig.
Man bräuchte einfach einen richtigen Paketmanager. Und nicht diesen Windows Store Crap. Ja,
unter Anstellungsfunktion ist das auch wunderbar. Du hast entweder den offiziellen Package Manager,
oder du hast die User Repos, wo du halt sagen musst, okay, ich traue dem User. Und das Paket
hat halt, wenn du es runterlädst, hat das Ding halt eine MD5-Sommer oder eine Hash-Wert
drüber. Du weißt, du hast das Richtige runtergeladen und gut ist. Ich kaufe mir doch kein Codesigning
Zertifikat, dass ich das Windows Anwendung machen kann. Ja, den Package Manager gibt's,
da sind sie gerade dabei, ich weiß. Aber bis das dann überhaupt richtig funktioniert,
wird schon mal, ach das wird doch nichts. Ey echt, bei Microsoft ist echt alle Hoffnungen
verloren manchmal. Ja, Flow 96 macht das. Als WPF-App kannst du das nicht verpacken.
Du kannst ja schlecht zwei Mainloops laufen lassen, einmal für WPF und einmal für WinUI,
das wird ja so nicht funktionieren. Aber anscheinend kann man keine Constant-Applications
verstanden. Codespaces, ja ich hab mich für die Beta eingetragen, ich weiß nicht, ob
das schon raus ist. Okay, man merkt vielleicht ein bisschen, dass ich angepisst bin über
die Microsoft-Geschichte hier. Newst. Wie sie hier einfach Scheiße erzählt haben
in diesem Issue. So nach dem Motto Ja, es kommt da mit der Briefview. Schwachsinn, kommt
es, kommt es, es. Mhm.
Wie hieß das Issue noch mal von dem anderen Typ, was wir eben aufhatten?
Sonst probier doch den Package Manager aus. Ja, das machen wir, den Package Manager,
das können wir uns echt angucken. Hat jemand, hat jemand mal einen aktuellen... wobei. Ja.
Genau, so ist es. Genau, sie haben seit 20 Jahren nichts ordentlich modernes mehr rausgebracht,
was man sinnvoll verwenden kann. Das ist, es ist so lächerlich. Erstmal abvoten,
erstmal abvoten. Ich will jetzt abvoten. Ich bin nicht eingeloggt. Frag ich muss abvoten.
Bin ich, bin ich im anderen Browser eingeloggt? Okay, ich muss es abvoten. Ah, easy. Ha! Da
hat er, da hat er geabvotet. Oh Mann. Microsoft, Microsoft, Alter. Nee, nee, ich fasse es nicht.
Okay, bei der Gelegenheit können wir das letzte Wishlist Studio mal updaten, das schadet nichts.
Was war denn das letzte Sinnvolle, was die rausgebracht haben? Wishlist Studio Code?
Nee, GUI-mäßig, GUI-mäßig war das letzte Sinnvolle, was sie rausgebracht haben, WPF.
2006 oder so. Ja. WPF war das letzte Sinnvolle, was sie rausgebracht haben.
Was sie ja dann irgendwie haben sterben lassen für WinRT und Zeug.
Okay, vielleicht ist das gar nicht so schlimm, wie ich denke. Vielleicht ist das gar nicht
so schlimm, weil vielleicht kommt das ja noch. Unpackaged Apps, vielleicht, vielleicht kommt
das ja noch. Ansonsten, ansonsten macht vielleicht irgendein Community-Mensch was, der das Bild
irgendwie, der das vereinfacht, weil aktuell habe ich noch nicht mal eine Ahnung, wie ich
den Kram überhaupt starten soll, ehrlich gesagt. Das muss gehen, ansonsten ist das
komplette Totgeburt, Alter. Ja, Henry, Qt ist wirklich das Einzige, was
halbwegs geht, ja, leider. Also aktuell hast du ja Cross-Plattform im Prinzip, so richtig
Desktop, auf dem Desktop, ja. Cross-Plattform hast du die Auswahl, Elektron oder Qt, das
war's. Das sind eigentlich die zwei Sachen. Für mich, ich habe es ja schon öfters gesagt,
für mich sind die zwei Kriterien, woran man sieht, ob man mit einem Cross-Plattform GUI
Framework quasi alles Mögliche machen kann, sind zwei Sachen, wo man nachgucken muss,
wo die meisten Sachen fehlen, und zwar gibt es einen Webview, einen ordentlichen Webview
für HTML-Zeug und gibt es die Möglichkeit, 3D-Content einzubinden, also nicht mit 3D-Content,
GPU-Accelerated-Content, also sprich, gibt es einen OpenGL-Widget oder einen DirectX-Widget,
das sind so die zwei Sachen. Wenn es die gibt, dann taugt das wahrscheinlich was.
WX-Widgets C++, habe ich mir vor einer Weile mal anguckt, sah irgendwie ziemlich wir aus
und auch wenig, wenig Tutorials und aktuelle Sachen. Außerdem, das Schlimme ist ja, das
kommt ja dabei, dass Qt selber C++ ist. Ja, es gibt ganz gute Python Bindings, was jetzt
auch nicht für GUI-Anwendungen unbedingt so meine erste Wahl wäre. Die C-Sharp-Bindings,
die es gibt, sind mittlerweile ganz ok, allerdings unvollständig, die haben nur QML. Und die
IDE-Integration ist dumm. Hier, das, warte mal, was war das überhaupt genau? Das ist
eigentlich ganz gut mittlerweile, leider ist die IDE-Integration, als ich das letzte Mal
ausprobiert habe, nicht gut gewesen. Das Problem war, dass man das Frontend in Qt-Creator basteln
muss und den Rest bastelt man in Visual Studio, weil der Qt-Creator natürlich keine.NETC-Sharp-Completion
und alles hat und dann muss man immer hin und her schalten und das eine funktioniert
dann mit dem anderen nicht richtig und es ist wir auf jeden Fall, es ist nicht schön,
es ist nicht schön. Qt kann man nehmen, weil, also vor allem mit QML, also die neue Qt-Variante,
wir reden jetzt nicht von, wie heißt das, Qt-Widgets, das alte, also da rede ich jetzt
nicht von, ich rede nur von dem neuen, das kann man Cross-Plattform wirklich nehmen,
weil das sieht Cross-Plattform auch gleich aus. Die malen ja ihre Widgets komplett selbst
und ich sage ja auch immer, ein ordentliches GUI-Framework muss die Controls selber malen,
ansonsten bist du immer darauf beschränkt, den kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner aller Betriebssysteme
zu nehmen. Das soll gleich aussehen, weil du hast das Problem, wenn das nicht gleich
aussieht, dann hast du so ein Geschiss wie beispielsweise bei Xamarin, Xamarin, Xamarin,
wie auch immer man das ausspricht, dass die ganzen Controls nichts können, weil die gucken
müssen, dass das, was sie implementieren an ihren Controls, überall funktioniert. Das
ist das einzig wahre, dass die ihre Controls selber malen. Natürlich sieht es dann Mac
nicht aus wie Mac und Windows nicht aus wie Windows und Linux nicht aus wie Linux, sondern
es sieht eben aus wie, ja wahrscheinlich wie eine Web-Anwendung zum größten Teil, bloß
weil es keine Web-Anwendung ist. Den C++-Hate, naja, ich habe mich ja schon öfters über
C++ ausgelassen. Es gibt so viele ekliche Sachen an C++. Man kann die auch selber malen
und es auf jedem System so aussehen lassen. Ja, dann hast du aber das Problem, dass es
halt nie so hundertprozentig passt. Entweder die einfachere Variante ist, du machst quasi
einen eigenen Style, der dann halt überall gleich aussieht, ansonsten kannst du nur versuchen,
die Sachen nachzubauen. Das wird nie so hundertprozentig funktionieren. Es gibt ja auch Windows-Skins
für Qt-Caps früher, die sahen halt scheiße aus, oder Mac-Skins oder sonst was. Ja, das
ist das. Also ich finde den Ansatz, wie du das mit Electron hast, eigentlich ganz sinnvoll,
oder wie sie es in QML machen. C++ ist eklig. Zum Beispiel, mein Lieblingsbeispiel, warum
C++ kacke ist, oder was sich zumindest das Standard-Cremium denkt, ist, warum gibt es
in C++, im C++-String, warum gibt es kein To-Upper? Gibt es nicht. Ich meine allein
schon, dass das Internet voll ist mit 206 Freestyles, wie ich in String To-Upper kaste,
oder nicht kaste, To-Upper mache, in C++, dass sie teilweise empfehlen, man soll Boost
für eine Boost-String-Implementierung dafür verwenden. Ich weiß, dass es das hier gibt,
aber, also, ich sage es mal ganz ehrlich, guckt euch das mal an. Ich meine, ernsthaft, ein
fucking String To-Upper, ist das euer Ernst, C++-Cremium? Was ist mit euch los? Was ist
das Problem, bitte schön an String, oder was auch immer hier, Upper, oder so. Das ist
doch hässlich wie die Nacht, das hier. Warum ist das nicht in der Standard-String-Klasse
drin? Das ist so ein Ding, wo ich mich an vielen Stellen in C++ frage, warum ist das so inkonsistent
und warum ist so einfache Sachen so kompliziert? Genauso, dass es drei oder vier verschiedene
Varianten gibt, wie du Iterator machst. Spread the Beast, 11 Monate lang, schön, exzellent.
Was genau macht das? Costa, das ist genau die richtige Frage. Weil ganz ehrlich, was
genau macht das eigentlich? Und vor allem, wie scheiße lesbar ist das denn? Also was
das macht, ist, es macht dieses hier, also Test-String, macht es zu Test-String nur in
Großbuchstaben. Der loopt quasi über jeden einzelnen Character in diesem String drinnen
und printet ihn dann quasi in Groß. Also schau mal, komplett wir. Dazu kommt ja noch
einmal die Geschichte, dass das nur funktioniert, wenn es ein poplicher ASCII-String ist. Macht
mal, wir haben es doch letztens probiert, macht mal UTF-8, oder Schwachsinn, nicht UTF-8,
macht mal Unicode-Strings in C++. Alter, das ist Brechreiz, kompletter Brechreiz. Weil
der Witz ist ja, wenn es eine gute Implementierung ist, dann kann es mir erstmal scheißegal
sein, ob das intern UTF-8 ist, UTF-16, UTF-32 oder UTF-69. Ich will mich da ehrlich gesagt
überhaupt nicht mit beschäftigen müssen. Bei.NET ist es teilweise auch schon ein bisschen
fragwürdig..NET verwendet historisch gesehen, glaube ich, UTF-16 oder irgendein Vorgänger
von UTF-16 für ihre Strings. Das ist zu 90% ok. Es wird eklig, wenn du 4-byte-Character
hast wie Emojis zum Beispiel. Dann wird es schon im Handling ein bisschen abartig, ja.
Aber in C++ ist es schon mal komplett wir. Quai, 5 Monate, danke schön. Hab ich vielleicht
schon vorher gelesen, aber nochmal. Huge Subscription. Scrusix, 3 Monate, auch nochmal
am Start, exzellent. Die Standard muss noch verbessert werden, dafür gibt es halt Boosts.
Ja, leider, leider. Ich weiß nicht, was die seit den letzten 15 Jahren machen im C++-Cremium,
dass die so einfache Sachen in der Standard-Library nicht drin haben. Zumal das Problem ja ist,
mit Boost, wenn du zum Beispiel irgendeinen Arduino oder einen ESP bastelst, da ist halt
außer Standard-Library nichts. Da ist mit Boost nichts. Max, wie machst du Emojis to
upper? Gar nicht. To upper machst du logischerweise nur normale Characters. Ja, genau, in.NET
ist das einfacher mit den Encodings. Ja. Und es gibt noch, wie gesagt, es gibt noch zig,
zig, zig andere. Ich meine, manche meine Standard-Lieblingstage ist halt über C++ zu
flammen. Was haben die sich zum Beispiel mit ihrer Lambda-Syntax gedacht? Ugly, genau,
ugly as fuck. Guck mal, wenn die erste Autovervollständigung bei Google ist C++ Lambda-Syntax ugly, das
sagt doch schon mal alles aus. Ey, oh, wenn ich das schon sehe. Das ist auch so was, was
mich in C++ abfuckt. Diese Iterator-Geschichte, die total inkonsistent ist. War es denn, war
es denn so schwer, war es denn so schwer, eine Array-Klasse zu machen oder eine List-Klasse
oder eine Vector-Klasse, die eine Sort-Methode hat? Warum, warum, warum kann man, warum kann
man in C++ nicht? Übrigens im Qt-Vector, in der Qt-List kann man das machen. Die haben
das nämlich ordentlich gemacht und nicht wie die Kack-Standard-Library das macht. So,
warum, warum kann ich, warum kann ich in C++ nicht sowas hier machen? Ist das zu kompliziert
oder ist das zu einfach für C++-Leute, sagen die, oh nee, also das kann man schon ziemlich
gut lesen. Das ist keine gute Idee, das müssen wir anders machen. So, und was machen die
in C++ stattdessen? In C++ kommt dann Standard-Sort-V-Beginn-V-End. Ah, frag mich nicht wie der Kram
überhaupt, wie geht denn das überhaupt in C++ richtig? Ja, haben wir hier eben ein Beispiel?
What the fuck, Alter, was ist das denn? Ist das euer Ernst? Kann man, kann man direkt,
kann man direkt so machen? Geht das mittlerweile? Ich glaube, das wäre ja schonmal ein Anfang,
wenn das funktioniert. Nee, nee, geht nicht. Ja, ich mein, was, was, was ist, was ist los
mit denen? Ja, das ist, wenn man nur, wenn man nur hier Range sortieren will. Ja, Ranges
ist auch so ein Ding, ich könnte echt Stunden über C++ mich aufregen, aber ich mein sowas
hier, was, was, was denkt man sich dabei denn? C++-Standard-Clip ist cancer. F, nee. Dazu
kommt auch ne Sache, die in C++ einfach absoluter Crap ist, wo sie jetzt mit C++ 20 oder, nee,
wie heißt denn, 0x oder so, nee, wie heißt denn das überhaupt? Also das neue C++, man
kann sich ja in C++ noch nicht immer merken, wie die Standards heißen, also das neue, was
jetzt rauskommt, dass man in C++ immer noch mit Header-Files rumhantiert. Es ist im Jahr
2020 kompletter Witz, dass man solche Dinger hier braucht überhaupt in Header-Files noch,
dass der Compiler nicht verreckt beim Compilen. Aber das ist nicht der Compiler, das ist wahrscheinlich
der Linker vorher. Das ist nicht verreckt beim Compiler, dass ich so einen Kack überhaupt
einfügen muss. Wo sind wir denn 2020? So, C++ braucht heute noch diese dämliche Unterscheidung
von Header-Files und Programm-Code-Files anstatt, dass man es machen würde, wie jede andere
Programmiersprache, die glaube ich in den letzten 10 Jahren, 15 Jahren, was auch immer
rausgekommen ist, die ein halbwegs modernes, gescheites Modulsystem haben oder in irgendeiner
Art und Weise Metadata haben, wo der ganze Kram drin steht. Kann man Visual Studio Code
Programme kompilieren und ausführen? Klar, wenn du einen Compiler hast, kann er ja hier.
Ups, warum habe ich das jetzt gestoppt? So. Warum? Verstehe ich nicht, warum das immer
noch so ein Ding ist. Ich finde es gerade Amazon, wie du dich so aufrückst zu 10++, da kannst
dich ja auch übelst aufregen. Es gibt übrigens auch keinen. Dadurch, dass die immer noch
dieses komische Konstrukt von Pre-Processor, Header-Files und Includes verwenden, also
wenn C++-Programme kompiliert werden, dann machen die es ja aktuell so, die Includen
quasi alles in einen Riesen-File und dann kompilieren sie es. Das ist ja alles nur Copy-Paste,
diese ganzen Include-Header-Geschichten. Dadurch, dass sie das immer noch machen und kein gescheites
Modulsystem haben, kein gescheites Repo haben oder irgendwo, irgendwie eine Möglichkeit,
dass du sagst, ja, mein Programm exportiert die und die Funktion, dass du irgendein Metadata-File
hast, was auch immer, halt irgendein ordentliches Modulsystem, hast du auch keinen ordentlichen
Package-Manager für C++. Jede Programmiersprache, die irgendwie in letzter Zeit rausgekommen
ist, hat eine halbwegs sinnvolle Möglichkeit, Dependencies aufzulösen und Module bzw. Libraries
zu installieren, die man braucht, die man dann auch gescheit gemanagt hat. In C++ ist
es wie 1917 Header-Files Copy-Pasten von GitHub. Ja, ich weiß, es gibt ein paar Versuche,
aber nichts hat sich durchgesetzt. Aber C++ ist nicht in letzter Zeit rausgekommen. Doch,
die sind seit, glaub, was war die erste moderne C++-Version? Zehn? Dreizehn? Elf, elf, genau.
So, die erste halbwegs moderne C++-Elf und die sagen seitdem, dass modern C++ quasi nichts
mehr mit Oldschools C++ zu tun hat. Also, die heben das, die stellen das so weiter vor
und die sagen es auch selbst, C++ ist eine neue Sprache. Mittlerweile. Und C++, vor allem,
wenn man halt ein Gremium hat, was da jetzt schon zehn Jahre dran arbeitet, neue Sachen
macht, C++ muss sich da auch am Standard mit modernen Sprachen messen können. Oder das
können sie nicht. Ich mein, so ein Package-Manager. Und ich mein, damit nicht diese Community-Geschichten,
sondern ein offizieller Package-Manager und ein offizielles Repo und ein offizielles
Dependency-Management-Tool. Ja, sowas, wie es Jam ist bei Ruby, wie es NPM suckt, aber
auch NPM ist für Node oder Cargo Rust. Rust macht das richtig gut. Rust ist eine Sache,
die kann man sehr schön mit C und C++ vergleichen. Rust hat alles das gemacht, was man von einer
modernen Sprache erwarten würde, um es dem User möglichst einfach zu machen. Wenn du
Rust installierst, dann kriegst du einen Package-Manager und ein Projekt-Management-Tool und ein Projektverwaltungstool
mit Cargo dabei. Du installierst Rust, du hast Cargo-Commando-Zeilen-Tool, damit kannst du
neue Apps anlegen und du kannst gleichermaßen neue Dependencies auflösen und alles. Wunderbar.
Top. Und das könnten die in C++ auch machen, das ist überhaupt kein Problem, aber sie
machen es nicht. Die können das ja auch meinetwegen rückwärts kompatibel lassen, da spricht
ja überhaupt nichts dagegen. Man muss ja nicht die alten Sachen rausschmeißen, um neue Sachen
zu supporten, außer es widerspricht sich. Da müsste man sich das mal angucken. Alleinschauen,
ich war jetzt gerade bei der Lambda-Syntax von C++. Die ist so unglaublich eklig. Also
die Lambda-Syntax von C++ ist sowas hier. Ich hoffe, ich krieg's jetzt überhaupt richtig
aus dem Kopf. Er macht erst einmal eckige Klammer, dann macht man geschweifte Klammer
für Funktionsaufruf und dann macht man den Body für die Funktion. Also dann hier macht
man dann sowas wie hier Printf. Also, das da ist quasi die eigentliche Logik, die ausgeführt
wird. So, und das hier ist, wo man angeben muss, sprich, welche Variablen man captchern
will. Es reicht in C++ nicht, wenn ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel sage, ich hab hier oben
sowas wie, keine Ahnung, int a. So, wenn ich das hier mache zum Beispiel, das reicht
in C++ nur manchmal, nur manchmal, ansonsten gibt's merkwürdige Compiler Errors. Ich müsste
das hier, glaube ich, irgendwie angeben oben dann. Oder ich glaube, ich muss sogar sagen,
dass ich nur eine Reference zu a will oder sowas. Also, ganz merkwürdige Geschichte.
Meistens funktioniert's allerdings so. Und was ich bei der C++-Lambda-Syntax richtig
eklig finde ist, warum hat man mal wieder Zeichen genommen, die in der Sprache schon
an zig anderen Stellen verwendet werden? Warum hat man nicht, ich mein, ich bin kein
JavaScript, ich bin kein JavaScript-Freund, ja. Aber in JavaScript würdest du zum Beispiel
hier sowas machen. Oder nehmen wir die C-Syntax, die finde ich auch ganz schick. In C++
könntest du sowas hier machen zum Beispiel. Das ist aber wahrscheinlich wieder für C++
zu lesbar. Da hat das C++-Cremium gesagt, ah, fuck, also wenn das hier jeder lesen kann,
dann brauchen wir keine Experten mehr. Und wer soll uns da noch Geld bezahlen, wenn das
jeder lesen kann? Das geht nicht. Ja, und die etwas längere Variante in C-Sharp wäre
dann das hier. So. Das ist Discard, den kann man übrigens auch weglassen, wenn man keine
Parameter hat. Dann hätte man sowas. Das ist doch wunderbar lesbar, das ist doch top,
da kann man sich überhaupt nicht drüber beschweren. Aber nicht so in C++. Vielleicht leuchtet
mir nicht ein. Aber genug der ganze, wir wollten uns glaube ich noch den.NET-Paketmanager
angucken. Was sind eigentlich Variablen? Oh, das ist jetzt aber, das ist jetzt ziemlich
basic von den C++ Sachen. Variablen sind Speicher, man könnte es eigentlich im Prinzip
Speicher mit einem Namen dran. Das ist eine Variable. Arbeitsspeicher mit einem Label dran.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, es gibt zig, zig Varianten, wo ich mich über C++ aufregen kann. Dass
das Ding zum Beispiel keinen gescheinen Inam-Support hat. Aber wir hören jetzt auf mit C++. Genug,
genug C++. Wir wollen uns den Package Manager von Windows mal angucken. Windows Package
Manager Review. 19. Mai. You are going to be able to win get. Die hatten sowas doch
schon mal. Ich habe sogar mal ein Video dazu gemacht. One get hieß das Ding. Und warum
gibt es da jetzt schon wieder 50 verschiedene Package Manager von Microsoft? Na gut. Win
win. Das Problem, was ich sehe, ist, muss ich jetzt mal sagen, warum ich glaube, dass
auch wieder nicht sich das Ganze durchsetzen wird, ist, Microsoft, es reicht nicht, einen
Package Manager in Windows auszuliefern. Man braucht auch offizielle Repositories dafür.
Einen Package Manager allein bringt gar nichts. Guckt euch in C++ an. Für C++ gibt es auch
4-5 verschiedene Package Manager. Verwendet keiner, weil es kein offizielles Plast Repository
gibt. Und das muss es von Microsoft geben. Okay, probieren wir das Ganze mal aus. Win
get CLI. Ich glaube, das probieren wir mal an unserer Windows VM aus. Wir haben schon
genug rumgebastelt. Haben wir überhaupt noch eine Windows VM? Wir haben keine Windows
VM mehr. Na gut, dann haben wir es jetzt hier. Übrigens, was ich verwende als Package Manager
aktuell ist halt der hier. Der ist ziemlich gut, finde ich. Ist ziemlich gut. Das Problem
dabei ist halt auch, es ist kein offizielles Repository. Es ist kein offizielles Repository,
das heißt, da kannst du dir relativ schnell, das wird von, keine Ahnung, 1-2-3 Leuten maintained,
da fängst du dir halt relativ schnell, vielleicht mal, wenn die nicht aufpassen, ein Virus ein
und das sollte damit nicht passieren mit einem offiziellen Package Manager. Oh. Windows 10
ist ein Insider-Build. Wir müssen noch eine VM installieren, Leute. Okay, easy. Oh, wie
spricht man das denn aus? Hulien? Okay. Become an Insider, excellent. Machen wir. Da ist
es wieder. Da ist es wieder. Man kann das einfach runterladen. Win. Win CLI. Excellent.
Patrick will Hulien mieten, okay. Ihr Patrick, Mieteser. Oh, die sind alle so glücklich
immer auf den, oh, Leute, was ist da los? Das geht aber nicht. Die sind viel zu dicht
beieinander. Okay, wir haben Hulien gemietet. Release. Aha. AppXBundle. Ja, wo wir gerade
wieder bei dreckigen UWP-Packages wären. Die halten alle die Luft an. Ja, genau. Wahrscheinlich.
Ja, stimmt. Irgendwie habe ich keinen Bock, den Kram zu installieren, aber mir offen System
jetzt. Oh, was sagt denn der Windows Store? Der Windows-Store sagt, es gibt Updates.
Habe ich das gerade richtig gesehen? Habe ich das gerade oben links? Oben links war doch
gerade irgendwas mit Updates drin, oder? Stand da nicht gerade drei Updates? Ja, hier, guck
mal. Stand da nicht oben irgendwas drei Updates gerade und ich habe es nicht gesehen? Die
Xbox Game Bar, your phone. Was, mein Phone? Ich kann mein Phone upgraden, das ist ja poggers.
Und der 3D-Viewer, ja. Dazu kann ich nur sagen, und gleich wieder weg damit.
Ok, Microsoft Desktop App Installer. Leute, irgendwie ist es mir dazu, eine Windows-VM
zu installieren für den Kram. Ich weiß auch nicht. Kennt ihr schon, ich zeige ihn immer
wieder gerne. Ich zeige ihn immer wieder gerne, den ISO-Download-Hack. Passt mal auf,
mal gucken, ob der noch geht. Ihr seht ja hier. Chat, nicht spoilern, nicht spoilern,
weil das verdirbt immer den Effekt, ja. Excellent Trick. Also, man sieht ja hier, wenn man Windows
10 ISO runterladen will, geht das nicht. Man kann dieses Tool runterladen, um dann, dass
sich selbst ein ISO zu erzeugen. Ich zeige euch jetzt mal was, was man machen kann. Ihr
geht einfach hier drauf und sagt Developer Mode und dann stellt ihr um auf irgendwie
ein Mobile-Gerät, sagen wir jetzt irgendwie keine Ahnung, ein iPhone 6 oder sowas. Dann
aktualisiert ihr die Seite und ISO-Download. Fertig, das war's. Easy. Easy as fuck. Easy
as fuck. Jetzt können wir uns ISO runterladen. Bestätigen. Exellent. Englisch. International.
Bestätigen. Sehr spät. Schon geil, oder? Das ist schon geil. Ja, und dann macht ihr
die Developer-Tools aus. Ihr könnt auch die Developer-Tools ausmachen, dann bleibt die
Seite offen. Und ihr seht, kaum sind die Developer-Tools aus, geht's wieder nicht mehr. Geht's wieder
nicht mehr. Microsoft-Mitarbeiter hassen diesen Trick. Wie behemmert ist das eigentlich?
Costa, es ist gar nicht so behemmert, weil, überleg dir mal, du bist ein User, der noch
kein Windows hat. Wenn du noch kein Windows hast, kannst du ja auch nicht das Windows-Tool
runterladen, um dir ein ISO zu erstellen. Also, die Seite schaltet halt um, sobald sie
denkt, du bist kein Windows-User. Ist eigentlich ganz logisch, weil als nicht Windows-User brauchst
du ja das Windows-ISO, um Windows installieren zu können. Also, ganz so low-brain ist es
von Microsoft gar nicht, aber ich finde es trotzdem ziemlich fail. Frage für einen
Freund, gibt es eine UDP-Porn-App? Wozu ist das Übertragungsprotokoll für eine Porn-App
wichtig? Brauchst du Echtzeit-VR-Porn, da TCP ist bloated? Okay, wir installieren uns
mal eine Windows-VM-Com. Scheiß drauf, machen wir mal. Schadet ja nix. New, Virtual Machine,
Custom. Geht ja auch schnell, dauert 5 Minuten oder so. Custom, Windows 10. Ja, meinetwegen.
Auch gut. 3 Cores, auch gut. 4096, ja, 5G-RAM, auch gut. Nutt, excellent, excellent, excellent,
excellent. Single-File, 60, ja, 40G reichen auch. Excellent, excellent, excellent, alles,
alles exquisite, excellent. Jetzt dreht er, jetzt dreht er durch. So, printer raus, Soundkarte
raus, da kommt Cortana gar nicht auf die Idee uns voll zu texten gleich. So, save. Die CD,
ist das ISO fertig? Nee, 40 Sekunden. ADB-Push, excellent, big-break-chat. UEFI einstellen,
ja, warum nicht? Haben wir doch gerade gemacht. Oder muss man das noch mal machen vorher?
Nee. Me-Came, 6 Monate, Dankeschön. Poggers. Chat, ich verteile mal wieder ein Gratis-Sub,
und zwar, wir machen das ja ab und zu, gleich geht's los. Ihr müsst wieder erraten, aber
erst wenn ich sag, dass es losgeht, ihr müsst wieder erraten, bei wieviel Subs ich gerade
bin. Aber vorher muss ich erstmal wieder einstellen. Oh, mein FFZ ist kaputt. Mein FFZ ist kaputt.
Leute, es geht noch nicht los.
Chat, ich muss nämlich erstmal einstellen, dass ich im Chat möglichst viel sehe. Ich
weiß, ihr spammt schon gerne, ne? Wo steht denn das in FFZ, dass ich die History einstellen
kann? Hier Chat, Chat, Kanal, Chat, okay, Inline, Raum, Erscheinung, okay, Breite, Schriftgröße,
ich brauche die Chat-History, wie kann man die verhalten, verhalten? Nee. Wie kann man
den FFZ, ah hier, Länge des Chat-Verlaufs, 5000, das sollte doch eigentlich reichen,
oder? Chat, das sollte eigentlich reichen. Also, okay, los geht's. Ihr müsst jetzt raten,
wieviel Subs ich gerade habe, sobald ich das hier reinpoiste. So, jetzt. Okay. Drei, zwei,
eins, stopp. Okay, also schauen wir mal. Richtige Antwort wäre 201 gewesen. Hat jemand 201?
Neonominus hat glaube 201, sehe ich das richtig? Und Kawaii Shocks hat auch 201. Der eine,
du weißt schon 201, oi oi oi. Okay, habt ihr gut gemacht, Leute. Dann kriegt ihr jetzt
ein paar Abos, wenn es funktioniert. Kommen wir mal, gucken wir mal, ob das klappt. Geht
das jetzt? Ah, excellent, nice. Funktioniert. Der Neonominus kriegt auch ein. Ihr habt echt
Glück, alle, die die keine Abos haben, gewinnen. Die, die Abos haben, gewinnen gerade nicht
mehr. Das ist gut, weil ich habe immer noch keine Ahnung, was ich machen soll, wenn mal
einer gewinnt, der schon ein Abo hat. Der wird dann hochgestuft, der wird dann auf die
nächste Tierstufe upgraded oder so, keine Ahnung. Aber ganz einfach abgesehen, das bringt
ja eh nix, weil ich von meinen 22 Emote Slots oder so immer noch keine, keine, keine Emotes
bei Pfeiffer gekauft habe. Dabei habe ich eine Riesenliste mit Emote Ideen. Schon ganz
schön, ganz schön. Monarch, Monarch S. So, da habt ihr eine Runde Subs. Exzellent.
Das ist der Neonominus, hast Glück gehabt. Und das Schöne ist, wer das hier regelmäßig
verfolgt, der kann sogar sich ziemlich gut ableiten, wie viel Subs ich gerade habe, weil
so sehr schwanken wird das wahrscheinlich gar nicht. Wo hast du die WinUI 3 DLL gefunden?
Im Ordner von dem Testprojekt, was man mit den Standardvorlagen anlegen kann. So, jetzt
müssten es 204 Subs sein, wenn ich richtig lege. Aber das Schöne ist, ich kriege ja
die Hälfte wieder, wenn ich, nee 205. Habe ich was übersehen? Habe ich, habe ich was
übersehen? Ach hier, x stürzt, was? x stürze dx, zwei Monate. Dankeschön, habe ich gar
nicht gesehen. Exzellent. Huge IQ Sub. Und davor hat McCame resubbed, auch ganz schön.
Sehr schön. Neonominus steht bei mir überhaupt nicht drin. Aber du hast schon eine. Ja,
keine Ahnung. Ja, aber die Twitch Tracker stimmen nicht. Zumindest nicht was Subs angeht.
Also ich habe gerade 5 Euro ausgegeben und davon bekomme ich 2,50 Euro wieder. Das lohnt
sich natürlich richtig. Ach und steuern, klar. Any key. Win-win. Ja Twitch freut sich.
Okay, Language, Englisch, Time Currency, German. Keyboard, German. So, German no dead key gibt
es hier nicht. Install. Exzellent. I don't have a product key. Brauchen wir dafür auch
nicht. Wir installieren Windows 10, Bro. Was ist eigentlich IBM German, so ein uralt Tastaturlayout.
Weiß nicht was der Unterschied ist zwischen German und i-German IBM. Können wir gucken
während wir installiert. Difference IBM German und German. IBM Keyboard German und
German. Ah, caps lock ignoriert die Zahlen, okay. Wusste ich gar nicht. Für mich ist
no dead key nur wichtig, was man unter Windows nicht richtig einstellen kann, dass der Kram
hier richtig funktioniert. Ja, so sieht es aus. Exz, Windows Installation, läuft sehr
schön. Haben wir Frametrops? Keine Frametrops Leute, obwohl davon scheinen richtig gut zu
funktionieren gerade. Dafür funktioniert es bei meinem Warzone beziehungsweise COD Mitspieler
nicht. Der hat jetzt auch rumgestellt auf Vodafone, bei ihm spackts jetzt übelst rum.
Aber es haben ihm auch DualStack Lite aufs Auge gedrückt glaube ich. Vodafone, Vodafone
Phone. DualStack Lite, größte Shit ever. So, ähm, ausreichend rumgeflagert, jetzt
bist du VIP Traffic. Jetzt mal ganz ohne Witz, das ist kein Zufall. Es ist kein, ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen, dass es Zufall ist, dass, ähm, in dem ab dem Moment, wo der Social
Media Typ vermute ich mal von Vodafone geantwortet hat, dass es ab dann geht. Das kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen. Der Zufall ist zu groß. Die haben gesehen, der Typ, dem gucken 20.000
Leute zu, also auf Twitter 20.000 Follower auf Twitter und der flamet uns jeden Abend
an öffentlich. Das ist scheiße, das geht nicht. Das müssen wir anders machen und schon
gehts. Was halt eigentlich total für mich gut ist, aber insgesamt ziemlich scheiße,
wenn man sich überlegt, dass dadurch es bei allen anderen ja auch nicht besser wird,
sondern marginal schlechter dadurch, dass es bei mir besser ist, es müsste halt überall,
man müsste sich halt überall wenigstens drauf verlassen können, dass ein Provider eben
seinen Job erledigt und es kann ja nicht sein, dass man sich freuen muss, wenn es mal eine
Woche funktioniert. Es sollte die Ausnahme sein, es sollte immer funktionieren und mal,
mal kanns Probleme haben, aber bei mir war es mit Vodafone ja so, es hat mal funktioniert
und die Ausnahme war eigentlich, die Regel war, dass es nicht funktioniert hat. Die Musik
ist voll MonkaS gerade. Das war Luigi's Mansion, oder? War das Luigi's Mansion Musik? Ok, gucken
wir mal meine Twitch-Statistik an, während Windows installiert. Oh, es gibt bei mir auch
gleich Mittagessen und danach muss ich Warzone grinden. Vertress, wann wollt man anfangen?
Also 13 Uhr gibt es bei mir Mittagessen, aber es geht schnell. Also wir können dann anfangen,
wenn ihr wollt. Ich arbeite bei 1&1, wenn du günstiges DSL brauchst, HMU. Was ist denn
HMU? Hau mich um? Nee, was ist HMU? Hit me up! Ah, nicht hau mich um. Wann immer ich will,
so, ja dann. Ja, dann geh ich jetzt danach im Stream essen und dann gehts los. Leute,
frage mal an euch. Ich weiß, die meisten Leute sind hier, weil sie Technik-Kram sehen wollen,
sowas wie heute hier. Leider war heute eher Microsoft und C++ Frame. Soll ich danach
unser Warzone Zeug streamen soern? Heute ist auch nur Windstream. Also heute verlieren
wir auch nicht. Ist es correct? Yes, is right. Keyboard-Layout, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Wollt ihr mich veräppeln? Das ist gar nicht das richtige Keyboard-Layout. Ich hab doch
eben schon das richtige Keyboard-Layout ausgewählt. Haben ja noch nie verloren. Nee. Und ich
bin auch noch nie sinnlos gestorben irgendwo. Nein. Zum Glück haben wir die Soundkarte ausgebaut
sonst käme Cortana wieder an Start. Hi, I'm Cortana. Was ist das? Moment, was ist das?
Loll. Ach du Scheiße. Ach du Scheiße.
actually
eine
Okay, das war recht aufwendig das parallel zu Setup.
Personal use, next, achja jetzt haben wir das Problem hier Offline Account muss man
anklicken.
Wir hatten doch eben jemanden im Chat der gefragt hat wie man Windows jetzt Offline
aktivieren muss.
Offline Account, da muss man zweimal sagen ja ich weiß, ich weiß, limited experience,
ich weiß, ich weiß, ja es ist mir klar, so Tests, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, excellent Passwort,
das geht mit der Home Version noch, oh weiß ich nicht, weiß ich nicht, Security Question,
Chat Name, Security Question 2, Nickname und what is first name for your oldest cousin,
ganz, ganz klar, cute chat, fuck, no, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, achja, die Installation ist wirklich absolut
failbar Windows immer, du musst erstmal eine halbe Stunde auf Ich will nicht klicken,
das haben die bewusst gemacht garantiert die die hoffen dass die leute sagen ja die
fault settings akzeptieren so nach dem motto das schneller geht total hängen geblieben
bis gleich also ich gehe jetzt was essen gleich wenn ich hier fertig bin 13 uhr kurz nach
13 uhr dann esse ich schnell was und dann gucken wir dann gucken wir dann gleich also irgendwie
so 13 30 oder so geht es los mit control alt entf kann man skippen ja aber aber nicht aber
nicht hier drin oder wie sendet man überhaupt control alt entf ich mache stream aus dann
spiele ich mich kurz am abend da mache ich dann später stream wieder an was gibt es zu
essen so hollandaise mit kartoffel und spargel und schinken so weiter jetzt müssen wir erstmal
for ever tools installieren edge ja ich dich man k.s. weg typical install so ok also wie
ist das ding jetzt win get win get kann man ausprobieren ok die windows vm höbe ich mir
mal auf wir brauchen immer mal eine windows vm und zum sachen ausprobieren ok epilepsie
warnung es ist nicht mal standard chrome edge stimmt es ist es ist alter alter richtig echter
edge was ziemlich bescheuert ist dass es noch die fault ist weil der wird auch gar keine
richtigen security updates mehr kriegen machen snapshot sehr gut excellent der chat heute
wieder massive so also die erste amtshandlung was man mit edge macht wissen wir ja alle
oder oder oder alternativ auch oder alternativ auch firefox oder opera gaming ja wie oft
soll ich das noch machen except run ach nee moment es ist schon da ja den brechen wir
jetzt ab als läuft ja schon ok also win get müssen wir installieren yes ach nee wir haben
es doch schon ja ja ok was auch immer also github wie ist das win get win get cli ok
release das da brauche wir ja das hier ist das übrigens der uv dieser komische uvp installer
glaube ich und die sache ist halt die du brauchst halt ein kurz ein zertifikat dafür das ist
das was mich vorhin auch so genervt hat dass es immer noch microsoft nicht auf die reihe
gekriegt hat
aha ok schön dass hier die hälfte wieder installiert wird so was ja ja ok und und und
jetzt wie geht das jetzt win get ah cool ok also was kann man jetzt machen win get search
ok also was haben wir da win get search gibt es auch so was wie list alles anzeigen nee
das wäre zu das geht ja nett naja das ist ja das nette drinne search also was searchen
wir mal firefox oh und visual studio code ist auch am start vim sogar vim ist da ok
probieren wir install und dann muss man wahrscheinlich mal visual studio code weil microsoft gerne
sachen mit lehrzeichen macht der kann keine dependencies das heißt der installiert einfach
immer alles oder was ja gut kann ich mit leben nice endlich mal was gescheites von microsoft
hier so probieren wir noch was anderes aus was haben wir noch search firefox mal gucken
win get install firefox gibt es hier schon was ah please refine the input muss ich dann
sagen minus version vielleicht so was oder die id vielleicht die id oh das ist eine
gute id firefox add das wäre eine coole syntax wenn die funktionieren würde ok kann
man sowas hier machen help install nee ähm weder kommandozeilen bedienung des todes so
vielleicht nee ok da gehts schon los install ah komm mal da hinten steht doch was kann
man kann man krepp ane ist ja windows crack weh feinst ist es unter windows ne für installation
firefox win get install minus minus id oh jetzt wirds big brain time was und dann minus
v ok das ist ähm komplizierter als ich gedacht hab
schein wieder deutlich komplizierter zu sein als man so erwarten mag ah ok ok
ahja also kann man den version angeben ok firefox 57.0 meine fresse microsoft kriegt
ja überhaupt irgendwas hin
als minus e was ist denn minus e exakt ok ok ah big brain moment root warum brauch
ich root um firefox zu installieren ok jetzt ist die nächste frage kann man auch
wieder deinstallieren remove nee äh was ist uninstall wie lösche ich denn was uninstall
muss doch gehen bin get remove was was ah microsoft
oh das tut ja weh warum ich hab grad echt mein kopf gegen so ein plastikding gekloppt
äh warum macht man paket manager der kein uninstall support hat
oh mein güt microsoft was ist denn mit euch los was ist denn los
feature request uninstall feature request für ein paket manager wo du einen feature
request aufmachen musst dass er sachen entfernen kann ist kein paket manager
also ich muss mal ich muss meinen kopf noch ein bisschen gegen das plastik schlagen
microsoft ich weiß ich weiß echt nicht was mit euch los ist ist doch nicht gedacht benutzt
zu werden nur eine preview ja ernsthaft das erste was ich in paket manager einbau ist
install remove search ich kann auch keine preview variante von was rausbringen was das
ist das kann man nicht mal unfertig nennen was was nicht mal angefangen wurde zu programmieren
da stand eine begründung ich kann echt okay im moment hallo windows komm an brah ich darf
es nicht mehr starten es ist broken es ist kaputt oh jetzt jetzt gehts wow oh haben wir
das jetzt okay okay ich starte ich starte es noch mal ich starte es noch mal okay okay
die begründung die begründung muss was haben ja ja ja dafür ist ein paket manager da
wie aber kann schokolade hier nicht deinstallieren das wäre auch übelst fail heilig sieben monat
excellent subscription moment moment ich kann aber doch jetzt auch hier hingehen und sagen
remove remove firefox warum kann man das da das kamen wenn ich das von hand über eine
windows funktion machen kann dann kann ich das doch auch machen über eine komando zeile
oder nicht und ganz ehrlich dann muss das microsoft da muss das microsoft forcieren
dann müsste ich sagen ja okay damit ihr in unser offizielles repo reinkommt braucht ihr
ein uninstall switch der funktioniert ganz einfach und wer sich nicht dran hält kommt
nicht in das offizielle repo rein dementsprechend müssen sie das aber auch als die beste lösung
zum software installieren pushen weil ansonsten sagen alle wieder hersteller scheiß uns noch
drauf was microsoft macht gestern was schreibt real relax schreibt gestern wurde bei uns
in der online vorlesung github als facebook der informatiker bezeichnet ja das ist genauso
wie sie alle spiele die schwer sind sagen sie das ist das dark souls der jump and runs
und sowas es gibt so ein paar dämliche sprüche also es gibt hier garantiert aber das ist
never going to happen okay mal ich muss es dauernden ich muss es dauernden ich brauche
ich brauche wir brauchen auf github github brauche ich ein cacw emote so ich habe gewartet
ja das ist von mir wo blows reacted mit confused ja genau scoop kann das ja auch ich kann ja
über über den sort party package kann das ja auch das ist das ist basic basic functionality
which is perfect ja ja natürlich eindeutig ohne den remove was ist ein package manager
ohne remove an ich muss essen das essen fertig krieg gerade schon nachrichten geschickt
das ist fail ist das fail ich ich bin heute ist echt ein stream ohne scheiß ich bin mega
enttäuscht von dem ganzen shit von microsoft erstens win ui komplett unusable useless crap
mit dem ganzen uwp und code signing zertifikat restriktion sie es immer noch gibt und microsoft
gehört github doch doch und jetzt kann der offizielle paket manager eine sache wo ich
seit 100 jahren schon sage dass microsoft sowas mal für windows machen müsste kann
ich mal pakete remove was ein schwachsinn okay leute dankeschön dass ihr dabei gewesen
seid gibt es irgendjemand den wir raiden können ich bin in wahrscheinlich später in einer
halben stunde stunde oder so bin ich wieder on und wir machen dann wie es ist wir streamen
wortel und auldwins heute auldwins auldwins sonst sonst nix ne gibt keinen den man hosten
kann so wirklich den ich kenne der es auch bräuchte ne okay leute also wir sehen uns
echt enttäuschende enttäuschende microsoft stream bis später machs gut